join our weekly Amazon giftcard giveaway
all you have to do is be subscribed to
our channel like this video and leave a
comment about today's topic we will
choose winners randomly from the
comments section hey guys
yesterday's various titles and
descriptions for the first three
episodes of the seventh season besides
breaking it down today I will also
provide an answer in a long-standing
question regarding relationship between
sense of Stark and Jon Snow which is
will Sansa betrayed jon snow over
Littlefinger in the second episode of
the upcoming season by the name stone
born there stated that king of the north
will face to revolt which many fans
assume is a conflict between Jon Snow
and Sansa Stark a scene from the season
6 finale in which sense a little finger
has suspicious eye contact many fans
consider that sense of disappointment on
Jon becoming the king in the north
and the ruler of Winterfell along with
possible sense of betrayal on Jon over
Littlefinger recently Kit Harington an
actor that portrays Jon stated ad
there's a part of censor that feels very
hard done by and because of that she's
going to make not so vulnerable
decisions sophie turner and actors that
portrays sense of said sense of learned
how to manipulations clever bunny now
she also said in a world where everyone
is a manipulator senses one of the best
it's becoming more and more difficult to
tell who is loyal even family
additionally Kit Harington has also
revealed that tensions between Jon and
senses going to escalate in season 7
Harrington said there's a definite
tension between them right from the
first scene there are the same problems
she questions his decisions and commands
he doesn't listen to her but as far as
where that goes or takes them or how
dark it can get they'll see it gets past
siblings wobbling it gets into two
people power struggling in my opinion
there will most certainly be some
tensions between Jon censer regarding
ruling over the north a bunch of
promotional photos confirmed that there
will be a huge meeting in Winterfell
regarding fate of the note and houses
that the trade starts by supporting the
Bolton's sense of a want to punish the
treasonous northern houses while looking
in the north will refuse to halt their
successors of those treasonous House's
responsible for their
Elisabet rail well there will most
certainly be a few conflicts between
John and Sansa regarding the rolling
I'm sure sensor will not betray John or
Petyr Baelish census aver that little
fingers playing games and is more than
aware that Petyr Baelish would let her
suffer or even get killed if that would
bring him the Iron Throne Sansa will not
be manipulated by Littlefinger because
as an actress such herself senses
learned how to manipulate she's a clever
bunny now sensible refuse will fingers
proposal to betray John and will chose
to be a part of the pack and stick with
her family which is not surprising at
all at least not to me since in the
season six finale sensor said that only
a fool would trust Littlefinger meaning
that she is aware that Baelish doesn't
love or care about her but cares only
about his ultimate goals all of this in
my opinion means that sensor might
cooperate with Littlefinger in the
upcoming season but now since is the one
that is going to play games senses the
one that is going to manipulate better
Baelish ritual in my opinion eventually
resulted his death in the hands of Arya
Stark now let's focus on titles and
descriptions for first three episodes of
season 7 the first episode of the
upcoming season is named Dragonstone in
description there stated that John
organizes defense of the north
Cersei tries to even the odds and the
nearest comes home it's already been
confirmed by a bunch of promotional
photos that there will be a huge meeting
in Winterfell that will determine age of
treason and snorting houses while Jon
Snow will also discuss the threat of the
night King and his undead army with
other northern Lords Cersei will try to
even the odds by making a new alliances
which will firstly in the first episode
be with Randall and his house Tarly and
later in the season with euron greyjoy
I don't think you even need an
explanation for the last statement in
description which states that the nurse
will finally come home at Dragonstone an
island which is the location the castle
of Dragonstone the ancestral seat of
House Targaryen the nurse was born on
Dragonstone and after six seasons of
preparations she will now finally arrive
home with her two large armies to read
dragons and with the support of a few
powerful allies on the night Daenerys
was born on Dragonstone a vast storm
raged and for this reason she is
sometimes called Daenerys Stormborn
while Stormborn is also titled the
second episode of the seventh season
inscription ER stated that Daenerys
receives
unexpected visitor John faces revolt and
Tyrion plans the conquest of Westeros an
unexpected visitor is most likely no
Sandra Ezra got to see her in
Dragonstone in the first official
trailer of the seventh season I already
explained John facing revolt earlier in
this video
well Tyrion planning the conquest of
Westeros is also not surprising at all
since Tyrion is the hand of the Queen
the third episode of the seventh season
is named the Queen's Justice a
description there stated that the
nearest holds court Cersei returns a
gift and Jamie learns from his mistakes
Daenerys holding court sounds like Danny
will have a meeting with John and Davos
in Dragonstone
Cersei returning a gift most likely
represents the met Queen returning a
gift of death to the sin snakes as a
revenge for murdering her daughter as HB
already revealed that Circe will
confront imprisoned delirious and Jaime
learning from his mistakes most likely
has something to do with his sister and
lover Cersei and as always let me know
your opinion about all of this in the
comment section down below I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace
you